so for example the simple projectile
class defines a non-touch function that
does some crazy things now I'm going to
walk through them so that you can see
the type of logic that can occur here
first off we ensure that we have a
physics body to make sure that the on
touch function isn't being called
erroneously in addition we also ensure
that the other physics body that's being
handed to us is valid and it has user
data as well otherwise it might be an
invalid object or a wall or some other
static trigger object finally we can
actually call other body get user entity
data to actually get the entity from the
game engine that responds to this
physics object now the simple projectile
class will actually spawn an impact
visual when it hits another object a
wall or the face of a robot this nice
little block of code here defines
whether or not we've actually defined an
impact collision and then I'll go
through and actually spawn an instance
effect object and allow it to start
doing its flipbook animation once this
is done it actually calls the deal
damage function on the game engine this
will actually reduce the health of the
physics owner or the other object that
we're running into by the amount
specified by this object this allows the
missile to reduce the health of any
other robot that it hits once this is
done we set the mark for death flag
equal to true so that later on our
entity will be cleaned up using our
sweeping process